[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing well harry
potter theories
the assortment i've collected for you
today is comprised of a few popular fan
theories circulating the internet as
well as a few theories of my own let's
jump right into it
5. avada kadavra's true purpose
if you're any sort of harry potter fan
at all then you should be privy to avada
kadavra
one of the unforgivable curses and one
of the most powerful spells in the
wizarding world
the three unforgivable curses are tools
of the dark arts and generally only used
by the darkest and most sadistic witches
and wizards avada kadavra also known as
the killing curse serves a simple
purpose
it puts an end to the victim's life if
you want to kill your victim then this
is the spell to use and it's known to
produce a blindingly intense green bolt
of light right before the victim simply
drops dead
the biological reason for how the victim
dies is not clear
but there are two existing theories the
first claiming that the victim's
internal organs cease to function after
being struck and the second claiming
that the soul of the victim is magically
ripped from their body there was a flash
of blinding green light and a rushing
sound as though a vast invisible
something was soaring through the air
instantaneously the spider rolled over
onto its back unmarked but unmistakably
dead but with that introduction out of
the way i want to introduce you to one
popular fan theory which suggests that
avada kadavra was originally created for
a totally different purpose
now it shouldn't come as any sort of a
surprise to you that avada kadavra
closely resembles the stereotypical
magical words abracadabra which we often
hear magicians declare when they do
things like pull bunnies out of hats
jk rowling even admitted herself that
this similarity was intentional
the theory in question suggests that
avada kadavra derived from abracadabra
was a spell originally created to heal
and not to kill
the words abracadabra in the aramaic
language the language spoken by the
ancient americans roughly translates to
let the thing be destroyed
theorists have suggested that the spell
was originally created to kill viruses
and bacteria not people
but that once wizardkind discovered its
capabilities its true path of death and
destruction began
4. hedwig's death
we all know hedwig as harry potter's
lovable snowy owl companion given to
harry's 11th birthday gift from hagrid
introduced to us right near the
beginning hedwig stays by harry's side
for most of the books that is until her
tragic death in the deathly hallows
specifically the battle of the seven
potters from our perspective
hedwig was simply killed by an unnamed
heartless death eater but what one
popular fan theory suggests is that
there is more to edwig's death
the theory in question suggests two
things one that her death had to happen
and two that her death symbolized a loss
of innocence in harry potter if we think
back to the battle of the seven potters
then you should remember that everyone
had taken polyjuice potion in order to
impersonate harry making it impossible
for death eaters to identify who the
real harry was
however there was one big overlooked
hole in this plan hedwig you see hedwig
ever loyal to harry would always remain
by the true harry side which meant that
during the battle the real harry
wouldn't be too hard to find
the therian question suggests that snape
who was in company with the death eaters
at that particular moment killed hedwig
on purpose
with the best intentions possible he did
so in order to make sure that it would
be difficult to identify the real harry
three trelawney's prejudice sybil
patricia trelawny was born on the 9th of
march sometime before the year 1963 to a
muggle mother and wizard father she was
a half-blood witch and descendant of
famous seer cassandra trulani
after cassandra no one possessed the
famous second sight or ability to see
visions that is until trelawny
she wore thick glasses that magnified
her eyes and she spoke in a sort of soft
passive voice that could quickly change
if she became upset
she was a very unusual and eccentric
woman that conducted herself in an
almost theatrical way given that
trelawny is one of the good guys and not
fighting for the sign of voldemort in
the ongoing wizarding world takeover
pushing for blood purity it should come
as a surprise to most of you that she
was rather prejudiced
let me explain
after being dismissed by umbridge from
her position in the order of the phoenix
it was on dumbledore to hire a
replacement divination professor
eventually filling the role with known
centaur forensic when umbridge left
hogwarts trollani was reinstated but
given that dumbledore wanted to keep
forensic on they ended up having to
share the role this deeply angered
trelawny
now i can understand trolone's
frustration with not wanting to share
her job
but she was fired and forensic had
nothing to do with it all he did was get
hired show up and do his job
sharing her position would mean that she
would direct a considerable amount of
hatred towards friends a
hatred that almost made her seem
prejudiced she called him names like
dobbin and the nag
or dobin as i prefer to think of him you
would have thought would you not that
now i'm returned to the school professor
dumbledore might have got rid of the
horse
but no we share classes it's an insult
frankly an insult she talks about
forensi with disdain in her voice which
is surprising given that she is a good
guy and one of the key themes in harry
potter is discrimination what do you
think
two the origins of crookshanks before
being adopted by hermione granger
crookshanks the half niesel ginger cat
was just a cat in a pet store that
apparently nobody wanted we know that in
1993 he's purchased from magical
menagerie by hermione going on to win
her heart as well as the hearts of many
others
but have you ever wondered who
crookshanks belong to before hermione
one popular fan theory suggested
crookshanks our favorite squished-faced
cat once belonged to none other than the
potter family supporting arguments are
that he had been at magical menagerie
for ages he knew exactly who sirius and
wormtail were in their animagus forms
suggesting prior knowledge that he was
maybe mentioned in a letter harry found
addressed too serious from his mum
harry apparently almost killed the cat
on his toy broomstick
this theory is a bit of a stretch as
there isn't much to support it
but it sure is an interesting one and
could technically work 1. snape speaks
in code to harry
this theory centers on severus snape
harry potter and one of their first
encounters in snape's first year potions
class
more specifically it involves a secret
message that snape may have relayed to
harry when they first met
snape makes it very clear right away
that he does not like harry
mocking him as hogwarts new celebrity
right before quizzing him on the spot
about different magical herbs there will
be no foolish wand waving or silly
incantations in this class as such i
don't expect many of you to appreciate
the subtle science and exact art that is
potion making however for those select
few who possess the predisposition
i can teach you how to bewitch the mind
and ensnare the senses
i can tell you how to bottle fame brew
glory and even put a stopper in death
then again maybe some of you have come
to hogwarts in possession of abilities
so formidable that you feel confident
enough to not pay attention
mr potter our new celebrity
tell me what would i get if i added
pounded root of aspardelle to an
infusion of wormwood you don't know well
let's try again where mr potter would
you look if i asked you to find me a
bazaar and what is the difference
between monkshood and wolfsbane
pity
clearly fame isn't everything is it mr
potter at first glance all this dialogue
shows us is that snape wants to bully
harry a bit he's purposely asking harry
questions to which he does not know the
answer however the theory that i want to
discuss suggests that snape's questions
are actually relaying a secret message
to harry however it's not a message that
he ever expected harry to understand
snape is a complex individual and the
message in question was simply for
himself
let's dissect snape's secret message
his first question to harry is what
would i get if i added pounded root of
asphadel to an infusion of wormwood and
what's curious about this is that
according to the victorian flower
language
asphadel is actually a type of lily
this lily means my regrets follow you to
the grave and the second part of snape's
question
wormwood means absence which is
symbolized by sorrow
combined this could be interpreted as i
bitterly regret lily's death
and this is of course significant
because lily is harry's mother
the only woman that snape ever loved
deep right to add to this even further
snape's question even contains an
allusion to his own death as asphadel
was once believed to be a cure for snake
bites which of course snape eventually
dies from and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you